don't come here don't come here don't
don't you dare oh boy I will you shut up
a [ __ ] I will smack the [ __ ] out of you
if you come around this corner don't
you're making a choice you know Gaza
maybe I don't all gotta get awakened do
we gonna run it and our hoo boy how much
I like what we do the video game ok ha
ha no no no no no no no aah gimme a box
ha ha no no huh Oh what's your [ __ ] so
dog Ted I don't need adduction was it
was it a bone top what do I have a boat
ah well why why why Oh get out of here
girl no no no no no no no no no all
right
ha I did what oh I don't even know my
own strength
I just ripped it apart aah aah
that's a monster that's a monster that's
a monster is about to lose your butcher
Hey oh honey don't make a loop don't
make a loop don't make a loop do not
loop oh [ __ ] you ok [ __ ] you
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo epic
leap oh ok I care here epic I said epic
aah
hey I gotta getta getta getta getta
getta getta get off huh huh huh huh huh